the one-year contract in the offseason will come
back after a second Achilles injury I saw him in
the downstairs just working out here he's in the
building here in front the puck tip but just wide
of the that God's got a stick on it a five game
career high point streak up high capitals go D
to D long shot big rebound Elvis seems to be all
right there Wilson he's always been an outstanding
player but I think he's more of a complete player
and concerned first and foremost for being that
guy here shot save gripping the stick you know
what I mean yeah he admits frustration says
may be the system but maybe not and certainly is
frustrated not being on the score sheet in here no
frustration from Elvis murin against a confident
goalie like Elvis mlin this is coming right across
the crease hot and you can see where that puck is
as Provo tries to keep Phillips away away from it
she Prov off here he plays it pretty well and then
he does a great job of Out muscling Phillips any
rebound Elvis he's got a snarl on here tonight
Jeff he gave Phillips a little look for keeping
bstrm perfect feed now the jackets into Washington
territory long shot here deflected high off the
glass jackets right back on the puck Adam fenelli
almost got picked off and did here's stroll slows
things down oetkin into the slot shot oh what
an outstanding had sa leak he's in the middle
of net waiting for this Puck and there he is with
that blocker off the Stick of the defenseman Sande
jackets counter oby kubel coming back and trying
to help his defenseman leading one way the puck
deflected Again by godson FR how about warsky here
to Gods rinsky says I'll take it great deflection
nice save lingren turns it aside oh your Che
fights off the check along the wall from the
corter centering pass and a stop off the Stick of
Danforth by Lings are even I think the capitals
have one grade a opportunity the Blue Jackets I
think have had three on my count and that's one
of them right there you know in the middle of
the ice players Alexander oetkin right Circle
again it's stro oetkin sees it wrist shot and it's
into the net may have been deflected in front if
not oetkin will see that goal scoring drought oh
I think it's mantha it looked like a deflection in
front nonetheless it's a power play goal and it's
one- nothing Washington that's with stro with the
puck on the left side well he really did a good
job of setting this up so he draws that Defender
down a little bit opens up the top of the ice
and then oetkin sees Mana in front and that's the
whole shift from stro stro shifted that defensive
box over a little bit and there's Mana in front
Big Scream big body and just got enough of it as
it sails past Elvis M leans and that's a Wasington
capitals power play goal Jensen from the draw
deals it on the right wing cross ice pass picked
Off K Johnson moves in lingren flashes the leather
and the glove save and hold second starting to
expect expect much more but nice pickup on a
blind just backhand throw of the stick Strow to
the point oetkin up high on the Str Wilson sets
the screen here's a drive off the goal post for
the Washington Capitals broken stick by good bran
there's that shot oetkin Alexander oetkin Puck
dropped by stro to the point countering here now
Wilson stro left wing oetkin in front Wilson and
doing the splitz to make the stop is mlin and he
hears from the crowd second period Elvis mlin with
another solid stop Tom Wilson right there looking
to poke it free heals it up high to Branson on to
zakensky jackets with territorial play here
now bemstrom singer walking in front scores
the jackets tie it up great work down low and the
jackets territorial play results in the tying goal
got the Washington Capitals down in their own end
they're just trying to get through this one but
the Blue Jackets tons of movement there goes Ben
from to the top he's got the puck moving to the
puck opening for time for space and that's where
bemstrom unloads for that but cylinder right in
front of this one looks like he gets a stick on
it that's a good thing about being in front of
the net you know he's there he's in the area
he gets a stick on it and as he turns he says
yeah that's another one for him so great reward
Carlson looking on the right one oetkin looks
for the pass and has it oetkin deals to the left
wing oh Elvis moves laterally to make the stop
they have developed some consistent disty their
recent play oh the puck take it away in front
where's Lincoln the stop from point blank ring
after that turnover wow oy kuel another a golden
opportunity less than three left Carlson
moving in looks down low in the slot scores
coming right back mantha Anthony mantha
second goal in as many games and it's
2-1 Washington work in the offensive zone
Alvis M leans with a big save but there's
a line change going on here and as they get
the Zone car right there so he gets tripped
on the left side of your screen so that opens
that passing option down low and then when it
goes low mantha in front he's got sweet hands
still chov into marchenko at the corner less
than a minute to go in front cha cop tried to
roof it and lingren will hold what a shift by
China go but chikov stayed with it and this
backand just almost sweep past Lin's blocker
there Maro waits in the right wi Corner battles
there capitals sweep it up but knocked down by
Eric Brenson here Che what a shot no mistake there
the puck settle down and he just ripped it stick
side and we're tied it two keep an eye on 10 good
support's going to get this Puck it'll move it'll
move he's going to go down but as he goes down he
makes that strong play right that chin and this
kid's got a wicked wrist shot there he curls
it in and rips it past the blocker stay away
from that Global lingren the Blue Jackets and
tied it up ninth goal fany Adam fanty Turning
Away hands the puck to good Row in front Linden
the save loose puck a scramble in the blue cake
the jackets say they it crossed the line but
the referee says no Nissan move of the game
right here Johnny Goodell with speed a little
chatter in his step and then that puck is just
a mad scramble how about lingren gets pushed
in and as he's pushed in see what happens here
exactly cuz he goes in off the Stick of vinsky
it looks like where's that puck oh Puck is
down Cole cylinder who has the first of the two
goals but it's Tom Wilson a left wing pass and a
breakaway moving in denied Elvis M lein coming out
makes the save he ended up getting under the skin
of Elvis M Le Elvis you can see Wilson gets thrown
in there fresh legs for the Blue Jackets partially
Puck punched ahead and now stro back into the
Zone on to Wilson less than a minute to go here
now in OT stro oetkin scores breaking his goal as
drout his first goal in 15 games and a power play
goal in overtime and this crowd is not pleased
here's a replay as that puck gets taken away from
Danforth it looked like he was upset he thought
he got hooked there but as they get set up it's
going to go to Alexandro vkin on the left side
of your screen he's going to settle it down and
there he beats Elvis High over that pad short side
shelf but you're right Jeff there was an electric
feeling in this building when those fans so
Elvis M leans go after Wilson made some big saves
everyone on their feet but Alex oetkin he's the
IGS Energy performer as look I mean he celebrates
every goal like it's his first and this one it's
been a long long time since he scored a goal